I'm going to show you how to stretch the
lower part of the body in the hips and
the lower back because the the typical
way that they teach us in school is the
exact opposite and I'm gonna prove it
and you can test this on yourself and
other people that this actually is true
so the first thing we're to do is we're
going to check the range of motion in
her lower back and her hips so let's
have you lay in your back
and so the first thing we're going to do
and it's helpful to have someone do this
to you you could do it yourself actually
all this on this one I'll just teach you
how to do it so you're gonna take your
knee actually on let's just take this
side here and bring the knee up hold it
with the other hand yeah hold your knee
and just raise it up okay so that you
we're checking the range of motion ok
now we're actually checking the muscles
on the butt which is the gluttonous
muscles and that seems to be loose right
ok so now let's just check this side do
the same thing on this side oh look at
that so this one does not go up so what
means that what that means is that this
muscle down here is restricted and it's
tight so she has a tight glute and
associated muscles on the right back
posterior side okay so that's one thing
now the way we're going to fix that is
we're gonna stretch the opposite muscles
okay so if the muscles in the back side
are tight we're gonna stretch the front
part right through here there's two
muscles that we must work on and one is
deep inside the pelvis and that's called
the psoas muscle that's when you do when
you do sit-ups and it just lifts up your
it connects the upper with the lower and
the psoas muscle you know that can come
from sitting and crossing your leg or
sitting incorrectly or driving and
they're in the seat all the time but so
this sides we're going to work on this
side and then the muscle on the thigh
right here from here so you got this
muscle here and this one we want to
stretch this now it's really good if you
can have someone do this on you but I'll
show you both ways why don't you lay in
your stomach what you can do is you can
just going to take
this muscle and you're gonna stretch it
upward right here
then we're gonna relax it going to
stretch it gonna relax it stretch it and
relax it stretch it and relax it now I'm
gonna show you how you can do it if you
don't have someone to stretch you you'll
take that it's the right side we're
going to take the right side right here
we're going to cross our legs and we're
just going to lean backwards this way so
we want to stretch all these muscles
right through here now there is another
way you can do it lay on your back face
up go a little bit close to this side
here so you do this on the couch or your
bed and you can take this leg and
stretch it down do you feel any stretch
here okay so we can just stretch this
right here relax stretch relax stretch
relax stretch relax okay
now so that's how you would stretch a
tight glute on the same side you work on
the opposite side now how do we test
this the the front part of the muscles
these are all the flexors that's so ass
and then some of the flexors on the hip
because we can do them both at the same
time like the tight size right here I
guess we could it's the same thing you
would lay on your bed and you bring your
leg down here so let's go ahead and have
you lay on the other so our actually
have scoot on the other side yeah and
then bring this leg down I want you to
feel that okay
now go the other side yeah and compare
what side is restricted that side okay
so we have a tight flexor on the so as
of course we just stretch this one so
okay so now you can sit up for me
and face this way all right so what's
happening is that it's she's tight on
the right but in the left flexor right
here so what we're gonna do is we're
going to stretch the butt muscle on the
left side so cross your leg over here
and take the knee and raise it up and
lean forward
okay good let's sound bring it up and
then lean forward with your butt yeah do
you feel it pull okay
so we're basically just stretching the
opposite muscle on the same side okay
so you can kind of just do this watch
stretch forward okay
switch forward stretch forward and you
can bring that in too you could bring up
bring this up and you're going to
stretch this side right here that's
going to take a lot of asymmetry or out
of balance muscles and put them back
into balance and your back is going to
feel much much much better this all
these things I'm showing you is good for
back pain now the next thing we want to
do is go ahead and stand up and we want
to stretch them test the muscles on the
side right through here and here it's
called that tensor fasciae latae so what
you're going to do is you're going to
take let me just take your hips and just
kind of lean your pelvis this way push
your pelvis into this wall yeah good
okay now feel the tightness now go the
other side okay which one's tighter okay
so we're going to stretch into the good
way go ahead and stretch this one too
okay and really push that out yeah there
we go I can do that about four more
times
yeah this is very very important to get
your back feeling good okay now go to
the other side now tell me if it's
easier yeah okay good have a seat that
problem comes from a lot of crossing
your legs at work and you know at home
or the way some people drive like this
you know so that just throws off the
back so the last stretch I'm going to
show you is a rotation so what we're
gonna do is we're going to take take
your left hand put on your knee and just
keep this straight and twist and looking
back yeah
we're rotating her lower back okay now
compare the two this side yeah just
twist and stretch okay which one's
tighter the right side okay so she can't
go to the right we're gonna go to the
left so we're gonna just twist her just
picture that you have a rag that were
we're just kind of wringing out the
water and just twisting her this way for
about an hour okay good
okay now go the other side okay good so
every time we do this we actually create
a turn-off response of the type muscle
so we're getting symmetry so if you
could if you take the principle and
apply to the whole body
you can really melt these muscles it's
going to help you sleep as well so go
ahead and apply this and comment down
below on my blog to see how it works